a good question right here is streaming
considered a real job no absolutely not
it's easy I made money the hard way you
ready you're extremely fortunate thank
you you are you're extremely important
am I fortunate you're extremely
fortunate for a few reasons one the I
how old are you 22 Yeah okay the idea of
a rich 22 year old before the internet
was non-existent outside of Daddy's
Money there was before the internet and
you and you were born poor for a normal
family did you ever meet a 20 year old
who made hundreds of thousand dollars
hell no [__] no yo W snake over I just
called people are getting richer younger
than ever before scary right you're
super fortunate right so and like I said
we live in an attention economy it's a
real job
the problem with it is what do you think
what do you think about streaming do you
think that this is a real profession
I do because I see it and I live it now
and I realize that we're working hard
it's not just the time in front of the
camera it's there's a lot of business
there's a lot of business behind the
scenes yeah I mean it's already been
doing a lot of calls for the creativity
kit there's a lot of work that's going
in for this February first launch
um and that's gonna be crazy and I think
for guys your age
um ages it
in some ways it's harder because you
there the things that I learned about
business I learned on someone else's
business so when I screwed up it didn't
cost money it wasn't a big it wasn't
like oh God it could be in legal trouble
or I could be in tax trouble I just made
a mistake they either fired me or
corrected me you know and said you know
carry out you know show me how to do the
job for you guys you you all of a sudden
thrown into you know this very fast
trajectory trajectory of success and you
have to it was really slow for me it
took 10 years to really start making
money but I think that that was probably
also a factor of the just the way the
internet was like once things really it
from what I know about you like once
this whole influencer thing really blew
up it's only the past few years that
this has become no when I started in
2014 the YouTube was at its peak
monetization in 2015. now so guys like
leafy's here and that was before
adpocalypse 2016. that's when they
started demonetizing and that's when
they started like regulating back then
you can get a million views and people
are making like 10 20 30k from a million
views it was stupid now like and then
when I started like actually making some
assets but I was making like a thousand
dollars for a million views we really
don't make that much uh yeah I mean I
was never making a lot from YouTube
money but like before when I was first
starting that was like when like gaming
videos just it was dumb how much money
people were making okay I didn't know
that but either way I just think I I
think you have to learn things really
the hard way and people don't realize
that it's an actual business or if you
treat it like it's a business it really
can be and you have to or I mean I don't
not sure how much no Aiden's actually a
hard worker I I've seen him behind the
scenes like he'll be at a party and just
like on the phone like not really paying
attention it's a lot of hard work uh
that people don't talk about but it's
it's fun to undermine it because
um comparison and stuff like that Siegel
brings girls on the stream so we can
talk to dudes while he gets p word
um pearly sneaky link okay no
sneako just have a main and a mistress
Haitian men's do it all the time come on
bro bro black men don't cheat
I will say it's a job because it is a
commitment thank you it's not a real job
the actual true problem with streaming
is that I don't think you learn anything
from it so that's not true at all I
learned every single day that's part of
the reason why I love streaming is
reacting to different videos I'm gonna
talk to Ryan Dawson like he's been
extremely canceled I talked to so many
different people I debate on a regular
basis I always keep I have to keep up
with news I talk about politics I talk
about different if I'm streaming for
five hours every single day you got to
keep the [__] interesting you have to
learn more and I know way more now than
I did when I started streaming I
definitely say too after streaming like
it Loki takes a toll on you like it
fries your brain a little bit like if I
do a multiple hour stream afterwards I'm
like [__] I just need to lay down for a
little bit I don't know if you feel the
same way if you're just like more used
to it at this point and you can just
keep going
absolutely you're learning constantly
all the things you just said he's
constantly and I'm constantly learning
about technology and algorithms and new
trends and what's going on and on top of
you know him um teaching him like you
know the legal side taxes and
taxes and all those yeah managing
project management managing people we
have a couple of other things going on
the side too so it's it's unbelievable
while I'm watching Sunny first hand and
myself we're teaching each other
learning things constantly so for him to
say you're not really learning anything
I'm not really sure
maybe the girls in his webcam business
aren't learning anything because he's
not teaching them much and he's holding
the Rays I don't know
also I learned a lot just from the chat
like talking back and forth I think you
get a consensus of what a lot of people
are thinking at the same time and
I I figured out about like the the
problem that needs to be addressed with
streaming and like what I was supposed
to do when I first started streaming I
had no idea like really I was turned on
the camera like trying to entertain and
then I'd be like what do you guys want
me to react to and then the stuff that
everybody was spamming for me to react
to I started figuring out about male
loneliness about people
um tired of the Godless nature of
society people tired of feminism what a
lot of guys were thinking about what was
making guys angry what they wanted to
see I learned a lot about the the
general opinions of a lot of people at
once because like what is it 9 000
people here almost ten thousand like you
get the sense of what
um an entire State like imagine if you
just do stand up or you're just talking
to a stadium you don't really like to
laugh and they'll clap and they'll do
all these participation but I I'm
reading this constantly this it's
information back and forth all the time
but you know Andrew comes from like he's
like oh this is like some new gen Z
thing it's not hard work I had to go be
a Salesman what's interesting in the
world before the the world let me tell
you something bro the world before this
garbage any job you were involved in
there was a degree of learning right
I'll give you I'll give you another
example streaming's example cryptos and
other examples if you make a bunch of
money streaming and let's imagine
streaming disappears still learn from
streaming you know like mistakes what
could you take all the skills all the
lessons you've learned all the talents
you now have and apply your streaming
skills to and make more money but please
tell me
good question
exactly I know
negotiating and managing and becoming an
arguer and absolutely not because you're
because you're streaming on the [__]
internet you don't understand anything
about true negotiation of between men
and arguer you don't understand anything
true about the true negotiations what
did you have to say I was gonna say like
comedy yeah I was gonna say acting
acting acting do you think aku's a real
job yes well you're right in this very
In This Very
fortunate bubble of super unique ideal
dream jobs every person on the planet
would love to have the what there's not
a man alive who doesn't want to be an
actor my man alive doesn't want to be a
streamers now all they do yeah so of
course everyone's trying my point is is
that let's say you go and get a normal
job a sales job and then you lose that
job and then you you can leave with
lessons well I learned how to manage a
schedule I learned how to go to look
after my clients I learned how to uh do
sales meetings without being scared I
learned how to present I learned how to
dress correctly I learn a firm handshake
I learn you learn things I don't think
streaming teaches you so yeah type of
one if you think that streaming is
difficult type of two if you think this
is [__] so Market yourself marketing
yourself to a degree is interesting yeah
that's the point of it but also I think
that a lot of streamers now are
marketing themselves just purely through
what people want to see
a lot of them are just doing dumb [__]
they don't even know exactly what
they're doing well they're just doing
[__] for shock Factor but it's not I
know what I say is shocking but I like
to believe no I like to believe I know I
believe what I say and I also like to
believe it has a relatively positive
effect in the world there are streamers
and kids out there which are doing [__]
which is not good for anybody or even
themselves just for shock factor
for all the people that just type 2 and
called it [__] why don't you do it
why aren't you doing it a lot of people
work jobs that they hate a lot of people
are in school and they don't tell me
they don't want to be in school I know
that most of you don't want to work
Matrix jobs if this is so easy
if this is [__] why are you watching
it and not doing it genuine question
because if it's easy instead of watching
The Stream right now you should be doing
it and monetizing it and garnering an
audience and having fun and becoming
influential well you know how they do
that right what join the creativity kit
you see what I'm saying what are you
about to say
that okay no but even like a lot of
these people work regular jobs where
they're trading their time for minimum
wage and with doing that you're gaining
less experience than streaming because
as a streamer you have to find different
ways to monetize you need to find ways
to push your content through short form
strategies you need to find a way you
know to make your stream as entertaining
as possible it's self-evaluation where
you need to look at your actions what
you could be doing better what you're
doing wrong and what you could cut out
manual says because the reason why I
said because I I'm gonna get like three
viewers in a year so it's not easy if
you can't do it yeah
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings